[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم للمره الثانيه منذ بدايه
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي يقر صفقه محتمله لبيع ذخائر
مدفعيه اسرائيل مقابل
147 مليون دولار متجاوزا متطلبات مراجعه
الكونغرس للمبيعات العسكريه الاجنبيه
والبنتاغون يشير الى ان بلينكن قال ان
هناك حاله طوارئ تستلزم البيع الفوري
للذخائر ما يعلق شرط مراجعه الكونغرس
للصفقه تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في
الرابط الموجود في التعليق الاول الاغذيه
العالمي واطباء بلا حدود يعلقان عملياتهما
الاغاثه في ولايه الجزيره السودانيه بعد
نهب مخزن امدادات تكفي مليون ونصف
مليون شخص لمده شهر ومهاجمه مجمعات تابعه
للمنظمين في حين دعت منظمه الصحه العالميه
لاتخاذ اجراءات عاجله لمعالجه الازمات
الصحيه والانسانيه المتفاقم في
البلاد الرئيس الارجنتيني خافيير ميلي
يبلغ قاده بريكس ان بلاده لن تنضم الى
المجموعه مطلع
2024 التزاما بما تعهد به في حملته
الانتخابيه مؤكدا ان انضمام الارجنتين
كبلد كامل العضويه ليس مناسبا وان السياسه
الخارجيه لحكومته تختلف عن سياسه الحكومه
السابقه وانه سيتم مراجعه بعض القرارات
التي اتخذتها تلك
الحكومه فرنسا تقرر وقف استقدام ائمه من
دول اخرى اعتبارا من من شهر يناير 2024
وفق ما اعلن وزير الداخليه الذي شدد على
الحاجه الى نسبه متزايده من الائمه الذين
سيجري تدريبهم جزئيا داخل البلاد مؤكدا
اهميه وضع برامج تدريب تحرص الدوله على ان
تحترم قوانين ومبادئ الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
بحسب تعبيره الى
اللقاء la